Как за 10 минут узнать свой талант в
заработках и стать миллионером Почему
стоит посмотреть это видео каждый день
огромное количество людей зарывают свои
таланты в землю пытаясь заработать на на
том в чём у них нет абсолютно таланта и
это Тупиковый путь Сегодня я дам вам
пошаговый план Как избежать этого и как
научиться зарабатывать деньги проблема
большинства людей в том что они не
фокусируются на том что является их
сильной чертой или их сильной стороной у
меня по этому поводу есть высказывание
что размер вашей маржи или цены на ваши
услуги зависит от степени распакованный
уникальности чем больше вы распаковали
свою уникальность тем большую цену Вы
можете просить за свои услуги И проблема
людей во-первых Они не умеют
фокусироваться а во-вторых самая большая
проблема в том что они фокусируются
зачастую не на том на чём нужно они
фокусируются на том На чём можно
заработать деньги а не на своих талантах
на на своих талантах Именно поэтому
Талант у них в одной стороне а
зарабатывают или пытаются заработать они
на в другом и вот когда ко мне приходят
ученики первое на что я обращаю внимание
- это на то в чём они талантливы что у
них получается лучше всего И после этого
я их Учу и настраиваю на том чтобы они
фокусировать только на том в чём они
сильны по принципу усили сильные и тут
возникает вопрос как определить то В чём
я силён Как определить то в чём я
талантлив каждый человек талантлив не
существует без талант людей Всевышний
создал людей и у каждого человека есть
предназначение и таланты и способности и
темперамент который Дан для того чтобы
человек максимально раскрыл свои
способности в исламе говорится что
человек на том свете будет отвечать за
за свои поступки за своё тело и за те
таланты и способности которые он
использовал Использовал ли он свои
таланты раскрыл ли их или нет это
является ответственностью человека
поэтому это вопрос не только заработков
это вопрос и вообще проживания
счастливой жизни Как можно определить
свой талант пошаговый план Это я создал
исходя из огромной литературы которую я
прочитал японской концепции икигай
благодаря своему опыту и так далее и так
далее первое просто Возьмите Составьте
себе список того что Вы любите
смотрите Сколько людей столько хотелок
очень много людей хотят разные вещи и
кажется в этом разнообразии трудно
разобраться на самом деле все люди хотят
только три вещи первое они хотят что-то
иметь так же как и вы они хотят что-то
иметь они хотят кем-то быть и они хотят
что-то делать поэтому первый шаг
Напишите себе три списка первый список
что вы хотите иметь прямо честно один на
один сидя один на один напишите что вы
хотите иметь второе Напишите список кем
вы хотите быть и третий список
Напишите чем вы хотели бы заниматься
после того как вы составите эти три
списка первый и второй список отложите в
сторону потому что их можно достичь
ставя цели они являются побочным
продуктом того что вы делаете то есть то
что вы хотите то кем хотите быть
является продуктом того чем вы хотите
заниматься поэтому вы берёте третий
Список чем вы хотите заниматься и после
этого вам нужно проверить а получается
ли у вас это поэтому вы должны спросить
своих близких друзей и составить список
что по их мнению хорошо получается у вас
второй список Составьте что по вашему
мнению хорошо получается у вас и третий
список просто Составьте список
артефактов различных дипломов наград
медалей за что они были вам даны за что
вам дали эти медали дипломы сертификаты
и так далее и из этих трёх списков Когда
вы Вы вместе сложите вы поймёте то что
есть в каждом из этих трёх списков Это и
будет то что у вас хорошо получается
дальше мы же говорим про заработки а для
того чтобы зарабатывать Вы должны понять
из того что вы люди любите и то из того
что у вас хорошо получается что нужно
людям вот бывает так что человек любит
кататься на сноуборде и у него это
хорошо получается Но разве это нужно
людям на этом вы деньги не сделаете на
этом Вы не заработаете поэтому вы можете
по сделать таким образом вы любите
заниматься кататься на сноуборде у вас
это хорошо получается А что нужно людям
Людям нужно не ваше катание А их катание
Людям нужно чтобы вы научили их кататься
так же как катаетесь вы и таким образом
из первых двух вещей вы соста
составляете третий список что нужно
людям из того что вы любите и из того
что у вас хорошо получается и таким
образом у вас у вас получается уже а Три
больших списка из которых вы выбираете
дальше Напишите список О чём вы думаете
каждую свободную минуту Напишите список
того в чём вы постоянно
саморазвиваться и благодаря этому вы
поймёте В чём вы действительно
талантливы для чего вам даны способности
и тот темперамент который у вас есть и
благодаря связыванию со списком что
нужно людям вы поймёте за что люди
готовы будут платить таким образом вы
для себя чётко Определите В чём ваш
талант после того как вы определили
талант это может быть не один их может
быть там два-три Напишите два-три
занятия в которых У вас есть талант И
после этого вы уже можете двигаться
дальше и составлять план дальнейших
заработков а для этого сначала Оформите
гипотезы любое Ваше желание на чём-то
заработать - это прежде всего гипотеза
ошибка многих бизнесменов в том что они
ставят себе идею вот я хочу сделать вот
это построить завод либо открыть пекарню
или открыть ресторан стой стой стой я
часто им говорю подожди Кто сказал что
это будет успешно Ну он говорит Ну вот
же рестораны есть которые классно
работает я говорю подожди каждый случай
уникален Вот у него Да но не к что будет
у тебя успешно поэтому любую свою идею
подвергайте сомнению и Называйте его её
гипотезой Почему важно любую свою идею
назвать гипотезой потому что вы не
имеете эксклюзивных прав на на то чтобы
быть всё время правым каждый человек
ошибается Мы все ошибаемся и нам нужно
минимизировать последствия наших ошибок
Так вот для минимизации последствий
наших ошибок мы должны убрать эго Иначе
мы не будем признаваться в своих ошибках
проблема в том что когда мы говорим вот
моя идея Я хочу открыть ресторан мы
продолжаем заниматься этим рестораном
Хотя он давно уже превратился в чемодан
без ручки и нести тяжело и бросить Жалко
А почему мы это делаем потому что наше
эго не соглашается с проигрышем оно
говорит Ну как мы же Крутые мы же умные
Мы же сказали построим ресторан вот мы и
строим из принципа так в бизнесе не
работает любую свою идею Назовите
гипотезой и тогда Когда вы назовёте эту
идею гипотезой вы даёте себе право на
ошибку потому что гипотеза подразумевает
что она не каждая гипотеза срабатывает
соответственно вся хитрость заключается
в том чтобы пройти Возле своего эго на
цыпочках не разбудив его и при этом
признав своё ошибочное решение если оно
было ошибочным Ну а если ваша гипотеза
оказалась верной и метрики и цифры
подтверждают что вы на правильном пути
то вам остаётся делать только одно
усилят весь фокус на то в чём вы сильны
что больше всего приносит вам денег и вы
будете успешны и богаты есть вот такой
вопрос бывают люди двух типов есть
предприниматели который например к сока
годам поменял семь Ниш бизнеса одно
пробовал разоряла закрывался заново
запускался А есть человек который также
к сорока годам уже 25 лет работает на
своей фабрике маленькой Папаши обуви
счастлив всё заме
В чём разница между этими людьми
какой-то из них идёт по неправильному
пути или вот у обоих Такой путь должен
быть по этому поводу я часто говорю что
основным мерилом успеха в этой жизни
является счастье если вы чувствуете себя
счастливым то не имеет значения размер
вашего бизнеса ведь в конечном итоге Все
хотят все 100% людей хотят быть
счастливыми я в своей жизни встречал
много богатых людей но не все из них
были счастливы но я ни разу не встречал
счастливого человека который считал бы
себя неуспешный поэтому А в случае когда
человек занимается ищет делает кучу
разных бизнесов
а меняет сферы деятельности и так далее
Это просто Человек находящийся в пути он
ищет своё счастье он ещё не обрёл потому
что когда он обретёт своё счастье он
обретёт покой счастье обязательно
связано со спокойствием и с фокусом
концентрации поэтому когда он найдёт
своё он обретёт покой и Он поймёт на чём
фокусироваться и чем заниматься и он
готов будет всю жизнь заниматься Только
этим а тот случай когда бизнесмен
занимается своим маленьким бизнесом Этот
бизнес может быть и даже и не растёт Но
это ему и не нужно Он счастлив ему
ничего делать не надо он счастлив надо
жить в настоящем моменте и наслаждаться
жизнью то есть Если он увидит какую-то
рекламу разных блогеров что на самом
деле нужно заниматься другим делом там
блогерство идти там на плесах торговать
всё такое то для него это будет ошибкой
Да вот идти для человека который
занимается своим бизнесом и чувствует
себя счастливым а не стоит вопрос
масштабирования и роста Почему Потому
что когда один из компонентов счастья -
это занятие любимым делом Если у вас
нету любимого дела Вы не будете
чувствовать себя счастливым кстати Об
этом я пишу в своей книге миссия
выполнима технологии счастливой жизни
можете приобрести в любом книжном
магазине Она вышла недавно Когда вы
занимаетесь любимым де там больше стоит
вопрос не о том как долго им заниматься
или заниматься или нет а больше стоит
вопрос о том как остановиться Я не видел
ни разу увлечённых людей занимающихся
любимым делом которые не хотят Расти
масштабироваться не которые не
хотят заниматься этим делом у них другая
проблема Как остановиться поэтому я
говорю когда вы занимаетесь любимым
делом вопрос масштабирования и роста не
стоит он идёт автоматически потому что
вам просто нравится заниматься этим
когда стоит вопрос масштабирования расти
мне не расти или как расти Это говорит о
том что вы недостаточно возможно любите
это дело и вы поме пытаетесь за счёт
инструментов каких-то за счёт
знаний вырастить Этот бизнес поэтому
если вы счастливы Если вы занимаетесь
каким-то бизнесом естественно вы им
занимаетесь качественно с душой с
хорошим намерением у вас будет больше
Клин
больше клиентов приведут к росту я
уверен многие из вас занимаются любимым
делом Опишите свои ощущения в
комментариях ведь это действительно
огромный кайф Дайте почитать другим
людям каково это заниматься любимым
делом и Стоит ли у вас проблема с
масштабированием или с тем как Как
выращивать свой бизнес обязательно
Напишите Поделитесь своими ощущениями